here we go there we go
there we are look at that look at that
mother
yeah somebody should have told me about
my collar I'm firing somebody I don't
know who it is happy Thursday everyone
I'm super excited I'm welcoming Russell
Brand to the show yes
band of brand for decades ever since his
talk show Big Brother's big mouth it's a
show that was so outrageous legal
wouldn't even let us show it
which sucks but even at the start of his
career he was a brilliant brain in
search of food at a time when the
shelves were bare but now brand has made
the most abrupt change in his career in
any career since O.J Simpson
Brad was a great comedian successful
actor bigger than most rock stars it
helped that he looked like Rasputin had
sex with Janice Joplin
they even had to play rock stars in
movies because he was better at it than
they
before he got sober he proved no amount
of drugs could take him down so he's a
comedian TV star movie star married to
pop stars hyper articulate dresses like
a Shabby hypnotist tall and handsome the
hippest guy in Shangri-La I mean he
inspired me to get hair plugs on my
chest
and what does he do he walks away from
it he walks away from it like Hunter
Biden strolling away from a stripper's
baby
literally he lets it Go and for what to
do a podcast because you know we don't
have enough of them
but he wasn't pushed he wasn't a victim
of cancel culture no it's the opposite
they didn't cancel him he canceled them
and no one does that ever he dumped
stardom so who was the side piece he
couldn't resist something called Truth
here's a taste
missing BC mate it was propagandist not
crackery just give me up give me the
specific
examples
ludicrous outrageous criticisms of Joe
Rogan around Ivermectin who deliberately
referring to as a horse medicine
if you take this vaccine you're not
gonna get it when it has been clinically
but you're participating in the same
game
I feel so bad for him he it's like he
wore that Joy Division shirt for nothing
but it's not like brand was knocking
just MSNBC he was knocking us as well
but I can take it I'm a big boy even
though I buy my shoes at Baby Gap
because I know that I am biased just
like I know that I'm short or strikingly
handsome that's the difference I don't
pretend you'd mistake me for Edward R
Murrow
mainly because he's dead and still gets
better ratings than Don Lemon
so what could drive a movie star to
leave it all behind to join an uncertain
future one that may in fact offer a way
out well today we're watching a
narrative pumped up by algorithms and
media corporations that incite conflict
because it makes money and it preserves
the power of such algorithms in
corporate bosses it directs our Behavior
by spiking our anger with every headline
and missing fact and as long as we as a
nation fight amongst ourselves we can't
fight them it's genius really if only
someone had said this three years ago
we're watching a narrative pumped up by
algorithms and media corporations and
citing conflict because it makes money
and it preserves the power of such
algorithms and corporate bosses it
directs our Behavior by spiking our
anger with every headline and missing
fact and as long as we as a nation fight
amongst ourselves we can't fight them
it's genius really
wow it's almost like I age backward
five years from now I'll be doing this
show in a diaper
so that's how I feel about Russell how
does he feel about me I bet Greg Gutfeld
vibrates as a human being in hatred
Greg gutfield vibrates as a human being
in hatred creates a bit of a swine and a
bit of a snide you're a silly sausage
you're stealing oxygen and you're
wasting time your name your weird facial
orifice looks looks like a caving in
anus and most importantly your views
your espousing of hatred your emptiness
your the echoing tub of your mind
very good
FYI after describing my face as an anus
he received thousands of complaint
letters but from anuses
by the way I considered that a
compliment the anus is very important
I can crack a stalk of celery in half
so
did I burn all my posters of him in a
bonfire no because I remember that I had
it coming
you know it's bad when a left-wing Kami
scum named Russell Brand actually weighs
in while Russell Brand is lecturing the
United States on bigotry the deadliest
form of bigotry radical Islam is spewing
from his homeland but he's too much of a
coward to actually focus on that you
should talk about what's going on in his
in his home and not in ours
so there you go I'm bad if not worse
which is why I'm grateful bran came here
because he didn't have to he doesn't
need me that's for sure meanwhile as
bran visits us and Bill Maher and Joe
Rogan and Tucker we see how Corporate
media in the government it protects go
after all four we know how CNN accused
Rogan of advocating taking horse pills
it was a lie so bold even horses said
nay
but it was a direct attack on someone
threatening their power
and now here's a headline from the new
Statesman about Russell Brand we have
lost Russell Brand
and why
you know I didn't read the article
because it was behind a paywall and if I
want to give money to progressives I'll
tip a barista
but their reason he's no longer saying
what they want him to say just using the
word lost implies they owned him in the
first place but now he's what Elizabeth
Warren would call off the reservation
and of course there's Tucker who adds
more and not less information to a story
that the media claims is bigger than 911
and yet when they get all this new stuff
they go after him instead and why
because he undermined their corrupt
narrative and there's this an actual
senator
last night millions of Americans tuned
into one of the most shameful hours we
have ever seen on cable television he's
going to come back tonight with another
segment
Fox News should tell him not to I urge
Fox News to order Carlson to cease
propagating the big lie on his network
and to level with their viewers about
the truth that's one of our oldest
Senators you can smell him before he
enters the room
it's a combo of Ben Gay and
he's calling a private company to censor
an employee
I think it's good to hear that out in
the open because you know they always
say the First Amendment only applies to
the public sphere but when the
government puts its thumb on a private
company that's censorship too and now
the FTC is asking Elon Musk to identify
all journalists who had access to
Twitter files any word from any media
reporters nope I haven't seen a media
this speechless since the view
discovered an old Donut enjoy behar's
armpit
foreign
and today this is from today watch how
these Democrats treat Matt taibi
first time that Mr
musk approach you about writing uh the
Twitter files you're asking a journalist
to reveal you consider Mr must to be the
direct source of all this
no no you're you're trying to get me to
say that he is the source if you're
telling me you can't answer because it's
your Source well then Dad the only
logical conclusion is that he is in fact
your Source well you're free to conclude
that well sir I just don't understand
you can't have it both ways no he can
he's a journalist he can't I guess if
democracy dies in darkness they're the
ones turning off the lights so it's an
implosion of a two-party system but not
in government it's the media we've been
stuck in the prison of two ideas for so
long you have two choices left or right
but now it's falling apart people like
bran Tucker Rogan Glenn Greenwald
mataiibi their voices that identify with
no one and yet Millions identify with
them if that's how the future looks we
should all be happy and it's thanks to
no small part to the epic journey of Mr
Russell Brand may continue says this
flapping anus
[Applause]
like a scone in a volcano he's as hot as
he is British actor and comedian Russell
Brand
truck drivers blush which he start to
cuss outnumbered co-host Emily capagno
she's like a hair dryer full of hot air
and electrocutes people in bathtubs Fox
News contributor captain
and his pronouns are bite and me my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrese
Russell welcome to the show finally you
know do I still look like an anus I've
been looking at you throughout that
throughout that monologue yeah and if
you resemble any body part at all it is
the most valued one ah from a male
perspective okay
also at that point we were in albeit
abstractly at loggerheads with one
another discussing some issues around
which we thought we were deeply at odds
but I can see over time we've come to
agree that broadly speaking
decentralization and meaningful attacks
of systemic power are the only way that
America and the world can progress to
allow people to organize their own
communities to have as much individual
and communal Freedom as possible to
permit people to live as traditional or
Progressive Lifestyles as they want to
and form new alliances is the only way
that we'll be able to confront
centralized institutionalized power and
these are more necessary now than ever
and I don't usually say that to people
if I think that they look like a bottom
hole Greg so you should be flattered why
thank you
Emily do you think I look like an anus
that's it this whole block is going to
be about
yeah what do you make of this do you
think the two-party system of the media
is dead
I think it's dying in terms of its
credibility and I think we've learned
that a long time ago I agree with
Russell that the new alliances you spoke
about decentralizing these alliances and
the the Points of Power
um we've seen how strong the liberal
woke left refuses to let go of it right
how strong they're attached to it the
largest amount of prosecutions of
journalists in terms of trying to
identify those sources occurred in the
Obama Administration here we have City
and Senator Schumer that's to your point
to crying in the First Amendment the
fourth estate the access to transparency
and Freedom of Information that's the
very last person on the planet that
should be attacking what is
disseminating video of something that
we've spent hundreds of millions of
dollars on Prosecuting and the left
always eats their own we see it in
Twitter we see it on social media if you
dare to not have that group think if you
dare to be an African-American senator
who's Conservative then you call names I
can't say on television if you dare to
not operate in lockstep the left will
eat you alive recently Reuters and
Oxford conducted a poll were they those
two men they're two animals
exactly assume but they asked who people
trust and the top 10 journalists or
sources that Americans trusted five of
them work at this network and the
articulates on that list
no but not at that time but the but the
the point that people articulated was
because it infused fact with strong
opinion so it's not about the the lies
that we keep seeing perpetuated by the
left now you've point you've pointed out
that is a game that both sides play but
it's about those who bring you the fact
and then say this is what I think this
is my free thinking analysis Joe Rogan
Glenn Greenwald and the like and people
respect and appreciate that because
otherwise they're fed a talking point
and a script
well done cat you know what I'm going to
ask you if you look like a butthole yeah
I mean yeah
[Music]
I mean it's true I'm all right with it
yeah you know if you're gonna look look
at look like something I mean like what
everybody has yeah
so some people are into that so
uh so look I I agree I'm way more
interested in this point at
conversations about like the people
versus the system then partisan
conversations of Republican versus
Democrat I'm obviously I'm not either
one of those things I'm not a Republican
or a Democrat I never have been and it's
just become so clear to me that it's
more about party than principles and the
one thing that's made that so clear to
me lately is the views on the military
I've always been really anti-war I've
always been a huge critic of the
military industrial complex I think the
Department of Defense is more like the
department War makes money uh and you
know just you can see how many times
they've lied to us for those kinds of
you know ambitious and money reasons but
that's something in the past that people
on the right would scream at me about
right and now I would scream including
you yeah especially you and now it's
people on the left are screaming at me
about it yeah uh and I think that it's
any conversation that we can have I
don't think that's necessarily a bad
thing I think more free thinking and I
can sometimes have a conversation that's
better with someone who's like super
left-wing for example rather than a
party line Democrat for example because
at least they agree that the system and
people in power kind of lie to you and
we should be confronting that and be
honestly searching for truth based on
principles well I stopped listening when
she said I look like an anus
you asked yeah
last word Tyrus what do you think you do
yeah thank you
um nice unfortunately man it's
we've become like the mob you know and
this is hot right now that people are
blasting each other but we're just one
street attack away from falling right
back in line they're just waiting for
the next so-called racist police
attacked or or celebrity decides to go
on a yacht trip with his wife and she
falls over and we'll follow that for six
months and not pay attention to all the
good that's being put out there to
people to pay attention to I would just
say this you don't have to pick sides
but whenever someone whenever you come
to somebody with something and be like
we have this photo here that shows this
and their answer is where'd you get that
from
who's your Source I want to know not oh
I can explain that or oh so that's their
angle well bring out ours I mean they
literally had a whole production team
I'm sure there's some B footage left of
their version of January 6 but instead
it was
you get that from who is it we want to
know we want to get rid of them tell us
now that comes from somebody who's
corrupt because when and just like if
you were cheating on your wife and
they're like we have this photo it's not
oh I'm sorry I shouldn't cheat on my
wife how did you find out none of your
business were you looking at my phone
honey how dare you violate my trust see
this is the same yeah unfortunately but
it all sounded good though you guys were
all on a roll thank you I dug that
it's true we need another weird
controversial uh Celebrity Death we're
just coming off the Murdoch thing yeah
you know what if you were to perish at
Fox News that would be an amazing story
I don't want to give up the gift of Life
simply to provide more fodder for the
media
we all agree with that
the sweetness of humanity yes just to
give you a bit of a laugh Greg yes just
so that you can pucker up the sweet
sphincter that is your Visage yes
it's not just about laughs it's about
ratings
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else